so you could have gone back and done it
and just played it as a local hire and
made way less money i still to this day
don't get residuals on that show
yeah so you know i think that's a
misconception about a lot of shows like
people think you know you get a lot of
residuals from things those dry up
pretty quickly and especially with
streaming now they haven't figured it
out so yeah you know smallville's all
over the place and nothing or other you
know sure sure um
but it was like i was negotiating like
as a local and i mean this was no
disrespect to the local industry because
new zealand has got wonderful crews um
and actors but we were as actors and i
don't know if it's still the same
because i haven't worked there since but
like bare minimum like
negotiating for a trailer
you know just uh
and you're about to do like a nude scene
or something like that and these were
the kinds of things that were being used
in negotiations and i was just i
remember coming over in like two weeks
within two weeks i booked like a
recurring role in csi and i booked chuck
so like one day it was like an assassin
with you know um
zach levi and like in
um
you know uh fighting yvonne and and then
in the afternoon i'm kidnapped by neo
and you know i was like wow this is
hollywood
man yeah you're really doing it totally
and but i had
i it was so much it was so collaborative
you know from everything from hair to
makeup and then i was like i made more
money
just
doing that so
a lot of people are like oh you know i
think at the time it broke there was
this like she was greedy she was like
i'm like i wasn't greedy i just wasn't
know
they could just make you look so bad
totally i remember when i've talked
about ad nauseam but then you know just
like he left small though what is he
doing after why would he like i didn't
[ __ ] leave how many times do i have
to tell you i got mad at kevin smith i
go kevin why did you say i you know
that tells i didn't leave i i was
supposed to do six seasons i did seven
is that leaving that's giving them
another [ __ ] year man yeah but you
know it's no matter how you do it you
look like the bad guy they like to paint
that picture and i do i do i mean it was
so like it's such a
you know non
thing and there was they replaced the
role and another wonderful actress like
got to have her take on it and no hard
feelings at all definitely a hard thing
to go through as an actor and then
another wonderful lesson like no one's
irreplaceable right so good lesson to
learn there um yes but what happened was
within that two weeks i met
jonathan littman and christiane reed my
brockheimer producers
on lucifer
and i did that and when i auditioned for
lucifer they go oh we remember you from
csi thank you so much for like that was
so wonderful so like had i gone back i
wouldn't have done csi probably right
and didn't you replace ironically
someone on
lucifer did um yeah if for whatever
reason it didn't work out at the table
read and um
and
uh
my understanding was there was just
creative differences and like what the
character was going to be